tombez nez au la situation s'étant
détériorée de façon considérable à
belfast
l'état-major m'ordonne de déployer votre
régiment sur place sans plus tarder il
faut pas t'inquiéter pour moi tu entends
je te promets ça va bien se passer
nous allons prêter main forte à la
police qui va procéder à la fouille
d'une maison dans la communauté
catholique
nous devons aller rassurer la population
il est important que les gens sachent
que nous sommes là pour les protéger
vous oubliez votre amplifié supérieur
alors rendez vous
ne croyez pas que je suis ici pour
corriger vos [ __ ] il est mort
d'un soldat man toit du conte c'est un
nom bien la photo vous vous êtes
lapidaire je pourrais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire maintenant on va le descendre
ils sont tous en train de chercher des
gamins
qui m'ont donné une légère service à
tout le monde et surtout aux plantes et
aux accords de vente génial bien compris
le temps tjazz l'homme qui roulait qui
vient juste de sonner boulet
mais aussi un message ils verront vous
êtes capable de faire jeu égal avec
heures
chut